[Music]
two weeks in Europe is gonna be great
that's really nice so nice to finally
meet you
in spite of man
[Music]
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation get gifts Parker but good job
to do are you going to step up or not
you don't want any part of this
hey everybody its charlie they dropped a
new spider-man bar from home
international trailer with a little bit
more Mysterio footage of that fight with
him at the big elemental we also got a
lot of details about how spider-man far
from home connects to Avengers in game
and what that timeline is so I'll break
that down there's a new round of the
IMAX ticket giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the trailer on
the video all the new footage of
Mysterio is just from this moment here
in his giant fight with the water
elemental that seems like it's meant to
be a big Easter Egg for hydro man
because the hydro man Easter Egg that
they literally pass by when they're in
the canals there were also a couple
extra scenes on Instagram you may have
seen when they released the last big
trailer with spider-man in customs just
trying to explain his pajamas
quote-unquote the funny scene where he
realizes that Aunt May snuck the stark
tech suit into his suitcase while he's
being faced with all these law
enforcement officials like a special
pajamas nothing weird about that there
are a couple extra scenes with him
referring to Michelle as MJ and then
there have been a couple of Funko toys
recently I think that have her brain at
his MJ as well holding a mace a lot of
you were asking me about that I think
the only reason they did this is one to
make the toy a little more appealing and
maybe there's a big fight that she just
happens to be on the periphery of and
she picks whatever's nearby up to defend
herself while spider-man is in the
middle of a big boss battle it's kind of
like Pepper Potts and Avengers end game
wearing the rescue Iron Man armor she'll
probably get a couple quick takedown
scenes but for the most part we'll live
up to her name and we'll be rescuing
people quote-unquote while Ironman is
off fighting in some big battle with
Thanos so this just implies that
Michelle is gonna get to do a few more
cool things they also said that net
leads even though he's still the man in
the chair will get a lot more cool stuff
to do during the movie he won't just be
sitting down the whole time talking to
spider-man's ear but Lu's timeline of
Avengers endgame leading into the
beginning of spider-man far from home so
the important thing that connects them
is that Amy Pascal confirmed last year
the Spider Man far from home picks up
minutes after the end of Avengers end
games so this will all make sense you
pick up in the beginning of avengers
endgame post snapped the world is still
reeling trying to figure out what
happened deal with the trauma of losing
all those people most of the surviving
avengers go back to the avengers base
and just try to track down every person
that they know and
see who's alive while they're tracking
people down they find Nick Fury's
last-known location and that's how they
get captain Marvel's pager so that's the
connection to her we know that she can
teleport so that's an easy way to riff
on that first scene where Thor met Iron
Man remember what happened is as they
were taking Loki back in Thor just came
out of nowhere
Iron Man didn't know who he was Thor
didn't know who Iron Man was they
treated each other like threats through
down in hilarious fashion until they
chilled out and realized they were on
the same side and started to work
together do not touch me again then
don't take my stuff you have no idea
what you're dealing with Shakespeare in
the Park
doth mother know you weareth her drapes
so I'm just expecting some funny twist
on that type of scene when Captain
Marvel shows up for the first time
because she got that page meaning that
she's expecting to find Nick Fury
wherever she comes back to earth so when
she sees the Avengers she has no idea
who they are
and they have no idea who she is some
brief gunslingers standoff moment you
have Iron Man out at outer space with
nebula macgyvering their way back you
also have ant-man coming out of the
quantum realm in rapid succession so a
lot of those things all come together at
the same time in Iron Man eventually
makes it back they learn about quantum
energy the quantum realm they develop
their plan for undusted everyone then by
the logic of big Marvel blockbuster
movies the Avengers achieve their great
victory undusted everyone right as
they're kicking Thanos's ass for the
last time so the Thanos witnesses
everything going back to normal
to his great horror oh my god all my
great work is being undone and that's
the big climax of the film so everybody
comes back in that moment everything
goes back to normal they reset the
timeline however you want to think about
it but that leaves the final act of the
film the conclusion for all the goodbye
scenes Lord of the Rings Return of the
King style so you have one scene for
memorial Captain America is still at the
top of my death predictions list you
would have to have some kind of memorial
for him then you have another moment
that sort of pays off the wedding of
Iron Man and Pepper Potts sort of a
happy moment then sort of the final
goodbyes where everybody mentions what
they're doing next and the people that
are permanently retiring like Hawkeye is
probably gonna try and retire again Iron
Man semi retires by saying that he's
going on the
world's longest honeymoon with pepper
potts and just shows up in whatever
future movie they want to bring him back
for and then as a way to explain how
spider-man far from home picks up
minutes after Avengers endgame ages
picks up as spider-man is heading home
to go back to Aunt May after they say
their goodbyes so that also explains how
he can go through that great ordeal and
infinity war fighting Thanos in outer
space
remembering dying then coming back to
life so that is the perfect explanation
for why he wants to take a quote-unquote
break from being a superhero and just go
on this summer vacation like a totally
normal teenager with his friends then of
course you have your Mysterio your Nick
Fury plot where it's like I thought I
was gonna get a vacation but they're
pulling me back in there is a new theory
that I've seen about this opening scene
of the trailer where they're giving away
the money to charity to help the
homeless people and rebuild part of New
York City I like the theory that that's
actually happening later in the movie it
also has something to do with a big
battle with Mysterio in the New York
City area because those elementals they
do cause a lot of structural damage look
at all these places where they pop up in
Europe if Mysterio has another battle
with spider-man back in New York City
then it would be another reason for Iron
Man to give some of his own money to
charity to help rebuild it but the
reason why I still kind of think that
this is happening earlier in the film
and there's more result of the damage
that dealt to New York City in the big
final battle with Thanos is because
spider-man is wearing the old stark tech
suit not the brand-new one that we've
seen him in and behind the scenes in New
York City so when he comes back from
Europe he's still wearing this while
he's swinging around New York City with
Michelle either fighting Mysterio were
in some other post-credits tag whatever
the scene winds up being wherever it
fits into the movie I know there are a
billion other questions about the
timeline of Avengers endgame and how the
Avengers bring him back the one easy
solution to explain how this all fits
together though is it in Avengers
endgame they fix everything but it winds
up being the moment before the snap
actually happened then everybody in the
universe just wakes up the next day not
knowing anything has changed that's the
only way to explain how the universe
could continue to exist on a regular
basis without descending into chaos if
you bring everyone back from the dust
because think about it this way look at
the scene with Captain America and the
trailer if that veterans survivor's
group just talking about all the
they lost awards all their comrades
imagine the entire world is going
through their own version of this just
trying to deal with the grief and the
pain of losing all their loved ones you
have to imagine that financial markets
probably crumbled the world is just in
total chaos
so not only psychologically are they
very damaged there's a lot of actually
really big problems that need to be
solved so if everybody just came back
from the dust all of a sudden and you
didn't reset the timeline the world
would still be in chaos financial
markets would still crumble it would be
utter devastation the only way to fix
everything and make it go back to normal
would be to literally make it go back to
what it was before the snap so there's
still a number of ways that that could
happen between the Infinity Gauntlet in
the quantum realm and alternate
realities so everybody post your
Avengers endgame theories in the
comments below there's a whole bunch of
trailers that are supposed to drop in
the next week new footage for x-men Dark
Phoenix Game of Thrones Season 8 in a
new Shazam trailer so just look out for
that whatever ends up dropping I will
totally make videos for it no worries
but click here for my early non-spoilery
Captain Marvel review and click here for
all my other Avengers and game videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]